[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ننتقل الى كلمه لرئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
الدوله هذه هي روح الشعب الاسرائيلي الذي
يعرف كيف يتكاثف امام التحديات وبهذه
الروح بعون الله سننتصر شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
الى جانب من كلمه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
كلمه وزير الامن الاسرائيلي فلنستمع
[موسيقى]
العشوائي
النار تجاه مواطني اسرائيل في غلاف غزه
هذه العمليه هي ليس فقط عمليه ارهابيه هي
مفتاحا على وجودنا في وطننا في اليوم ذاته
المنظومه الامنيه استعدت بشكل فوري
للغتيال قياده الجهات الاسلاميه في قطاع
غزه هذه القياده القاتله التي كانت مسؤوله
عن اطلاق الصواريخ وارسال عمليات كثيره في
الغربيه ضد مواطنين اسرائيليين
احد
غانم
بدماء وافراد عائله
وكان من مخططي هذه العمليه التي ادت الى
مقتل
صالحه التي كانت في الشهر الثامن لحملها
واربع بناتها في منطقه 19 عام ولم يقربون
كانوا ضالعين في عمليات ارهابيه كثيره
وخاصه هنا وفي الاونه الاخيره وفي الايام
الاخيره كانوا يريدون اخراج الارهاب من
قطاع غزه
[موسيقى]
وبعد النضجت الظروف الجيش الاسرائيلي
والمخابرات مع العامه
[موسيقى]
العمليه انجزت بالكامل قياده الجيش
الاسلامي في قطاع غزه اوبيده من حاول من
جربنا
[موسيقى]
دوله اسرائيل وقوه المنظومه الامنيه
الليله اثبتنا لكل من اراد
ان نذكره اننا مصممون على احباط التهديدات
وان نرد على كل من يحاول ان يهددنا قمنا
بذلك في الماضي فعلنا ذلك اليوم وسنفعل
ذلك في المستقبل في كل مره سيطلب منا ذلك
الثمن الباهظ الذي قمنا بجبايته هو الرد
الواضح لدوله اسرائيل تمام كل الجهاز
الارهابيه التي اخطات خطا فادحا حينما
اعتقدت انها يمكن ان تهدد
والان الى التاسعه مشاهدينا والبدايه مع
العناوين
[تصفيق]
ترقب لرد الفصائل الفلسطينيه على قصف غزه
ونتنياهو يعلن استعداده لخوض معركه متعدده
الجبهات
قيادات الكريم
ويقول قاده الجيش الروسي يحاولون تضليل
بوتين
في اول لقاء منذ 12 عاما وزير الخارجيه
السوري والتركي يجتمعان غدا في العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو
اعتقال عمران خان يشعل غضبا في باكستان
وانصاره يردون باقتحام مقر عسكريه
واستخباراتيه للحكومه
[موسيقى]
نبدا مشاهدينا من غزه التي تشهد توترا في
الساعات الماضيه بعدما قتلت اسرائيل ثلاثه
من ابرز القاده العسكريين لحركه الجهاد
التي توعدت برد ورد ايضا رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي نتنياهو توعد ايضا بمزيد من
التصعيد حيث اعلن استعداد جيشه لكل
الاحتمالات والقتال على كل الجبهات
نتنياهو وفقا للصحيفه الاسرائيليه كان قد
ابلغ كبار مستشاري الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن بانشون عمليه استباقيه على غزه كان
على جدول الاعمال وذلك قبل يوم من اطلاق
الهجوم على القطاع
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اعود الى مؤتمر الصحافي لرئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتانياه هو وزير الدفاع
عقب انتهاء جلسه الحكومه المصغره دخول
تلخيص السلمة
الاجهزه الامنيه ان تكون مستعده لاي
سيناريو وان تكون متعدده الجبهات هذا
المساء اقول لاعدائنا
اي اي رد من قبلكم سيكون هناك ردا حاسما
ضربه قويه من اسرائيل في هذه المعركه كلنا
نقف معا كاخوه انا اقدر الحصانه التي لدى
الشعب المواطني اسرائيل واشد على ايدي
سكان الجنوب على هذا الصمود
والجيش واجهزه الامن واصل الاستماع
لتعليمات الجبهه الداخليه اريد ان اشكر
وزير الدفاع والرئيس هيئه الاركان ورئيس
الشباب ورئيس المشاهد وكل المقاتلين برا
وبحرا وجوا الذين يقومون الان بهذا العمل
في لحظه الحقيقه الكل يكون معا في
المواجهه نحن نستطيع ان نتكتل في مواجهه
اي عمليه واي اعتداء علينا شكرا لكم
مسؤول استخبارات اسرائيلي اكد للقناه
الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه بان عمليه غزه
استهدفت حركه الجهاد وليس حماس مضيف انهم
مستعدون لكل السيناريوهات اذا قررت حماس
الانضمام لرد حركه الجهاد وجاء هذا عقب
انتهاء جلسه المشاورات الامنيه بين رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو ووزير الدفاع
ومسؤولين الاستخبارات لتقييم الوضع الامني
بدورها اعلنت السلطه الفلسطينيه ارتفاع
عدد قتل الغارات الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه
الى 15 قتيلا بعد مقتل الفلسطينيين اثنين
في غاره جديده استهدفت سياره جنوب قطاع
غزه وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه استهدف
خليه كانت تنوي اطلاق صاروخ مضاد للدروح
[موسيقى]
بنفس الاسلوب قوات خاصه اسرائيليه تدخل
البلده القديمه من نابلس تتبعها عشرات
الاليات العسكريه القوات الخاصه حاصرت
منزلا في حاره القريون والاليات الثقيله
حاصرت البلده القديمه من نابلس ومباشر عن
اتجهنا نحو حمزه وغم و ربط ممكن نوعا ما
اخدع لا تحقيق عزله بغرفه بغرفه معينه
تقريبا اعدوا تقريبا ساعه ولبين ما يقول
لي انهن خرجوا وانسحبوا من المنطقه
اشتباكات مسلحه رافقت اقتحام الجيش
الاسرائيلي لنابلس اسفرت عن اصابه جندي
اسرائيلي
و13 فلسطينيا بالرصاص وسبعين بالاختناق
جراء استنشاق الغاز المسيلي للدموع اضافه
الى اعتقال فلسطينيين تقول اسرائيل انهما
هدف العمليه رغم ان العمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه اليوم في نابلس لم توقع ضحايا
الا انها تعيد التاكيد ان الفعل ورده
الفعل تبقي دوامه العنف دائره في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه من حاره القريون في البلده
القديمه بنابلس خالد القاسم العربيه
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من القدس زياد حلبي
مدير مكتب العربيه في فلسطين زياد قبل ان
اسال عن الاوضاع الميدانيه هناك سابدا مع
المؤتمر الصحفي الذي سمعنا لرئيس الوزراء
ووزير الدفاع اعاده التشديد على يعني
القبضه الحديديه
لاسرائيل التي تعتبر ضمن يعني صلب سياسه
الرادعه الاسرائيليه ما معناها بصراع
الدائره الان
طبعا نحن ما زلنا في المنطقه الجنوبيه
الحدوديه حتى الان بدون ان نشكل مؤتمر كان
متوقعا عمليا لم يسق جديدا دراماتيكيا
فيما قاله نتنياهو ولا وزير الدفاع عمليا
ملاحظ هو انه اراد ان يسوق جبهه موحده وان
يعني يقول ان هناك تهديدات اسرائيليه الان
للفصائل لحماس ان شاركت هي ايضا في
العمليات بان الاغتيالات قد تستمر
والضربات قد تستمر وايضا في اشارات لجبهات
اخرى وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي قال انه يمكن
استنساخ ما قمنا به في جبهات اخرى بمعنى
تهديدات لجبهات اخرى في لبنان وسوريا وما
الى ذلك الواضح بان نتنياهو عمليا اراد
هذا المشهد للاسرائيليين في المقام الاول
ان يروا بان من حوله كل المؤسسه الامنيه
ممثله بوزير الدفاع وحتى رئيس الموساد
والاستخبارات والمخابرات
في سيئه الاركان لانه يدرك تماما بان بعد
انتهاء المعركه عمليا ستبدا الانتقادات
بانه قام بالاغتيالات فقط لاسباب سياسيه
داخليه هذا سياتي بعد انتهاء المواجهه
الان لا احد ينتقد هذه الحكومه لهذا راينا
بان نتنياهو يخرج مع كامل الهيئه الامنيه
كي يقول بان القرار ليس له وحده وانما
باجماع كل هؤلاء
زياد الصوره من على الحدود والترقب يعني
للساعات المقبله بمسار هذا النزاع
هذا صحيح جدا الانتظار ما يزال سيدا
للموقف وهو بحد ذاته لافت نتحدث عن نحو 20
ساعه الان من شد الاعصاب في اسرائيل في
انتظار رد الفلسطينيه وخاصه طبعا حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي
كل الوقت اسرائيل تنتظر
وتحاول ان تفهم ما سيحدث عمليا هذه الساعه
بالذات هي الساعه التاسعه بالتوقيت فلسطين
عاده الجهاد الاسلامي كانت تطلق فيها
الصواريخ ساعه البهاء تسميها نسبه الى
اغتيال قائد المنطقه الشماليه قبل سنوات
بيدي حكومه نتنياهو في حينه عمليا بهاء
ابو العطا وبالتالي هذا لم يتم ايضا ما قد
يعني ياخذنا الى ساعات الفجر عمليا ساعات
تنفيذ الاغتيالات الاسرائيليه ربما قد
يكون الرد الصاروخي ايا كان تل ابيب فتحت
الملاجئ العامه الان في ربما اشاره الى
التخوف من استهداف تل ابيب بالذات ومطار
تل ابيب من قبل الجهاد الاسلامي والفصائل
الفلسطينيه ربما لاحقا هذه الليله شكرا لك
زياده على كل حال سنبقى نتابع معك الصوره
بالساعات المقبله شكرا لك
قال مسؤول امن اسرائيلي لصحيفه يدعو
دحرانوت الاسرائيليه بان اسرائيل لا
تستهدف تصعيدا عسكريا موسعا بعد الغارات
التي شنتها بلاده على قطاع غزه ونقلت
الصحيفه الاسرائيليه عن المسؤول الامني
لان اسرائيل ما زالت تترقب ردا من غزه بعد
القصف اللافت الى ان حركه الحركه
الفلسطينيه سترد رغم صدمتها على حد قولها
الى ذلك ادانا منسق الامم المتحده لعمليه
السلام في الشرق الاوسط مقتل مدنيين في
الغارات الاسرائيليه على غزه داعيا جميع
الاطراف المعنيه الى ممارسه اقصى درجات
ضبط النفس وقال في حسابه على التويتر انه
لا يزال على تواصل مع كل الاطراف في مسعى
لتجنب نشوب صراع اوسع ذي تداعيات مدمره
فيما ادانت السلطه الفلسطينيه الهجوم
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه واصفه الهجوم
بانه ارهاب دوله منظم
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من رام الله عزام
الاحمد عضو اللجنه التنفيذيه لمنظمه
التحرير الفلسطينيه استاذ سابدا يعني من
هذا الترقب الذي يعيشه العالم بالخارج
والفلسطينيين الرد كيف سيكون بالساعات
المقبله
يعني
المساله ليست مساله فعل ورد فعل فقط
بقدر ان التفكير
الدقيق بكيفيه الرد سيبقى حاضرا امامنا
وامام الشعب الفلسطيني وكل القوى
الفلسطينيه
مهما كان الخلافات السائده بينهما
استمرار العدوان الاسرائيلي
الارهابي على غزه اليوم
وفي الفجر في نفس الوقت في نابلس وقبل
يومين في طولكرم ونابلس وجنين والقدس
وهكذا لذلك ليس مفر امامنا الا الصمود
واستمرار المقاومه بكل الاشكال المتاحه
وفق الواقع الموجود
واليوم عندما تقوم اسرائيل باستخدام
اربعين طائره من اجل قصف عائله ثلاث
عائلات في منازلها وهم نيام بغض النظر
ماذا يعمل رب العائله واين موقعه هنا او
هناك او في صلب المقاومه ما ذنب اطفاله
وزوجته وزوجاتهم ما ذنبهم
يعني هذا الكم الهائل من المدنيين الذين
يسقطوا كل يوم
ونحن اقول ايضا كفلسطينيين موحدين ويجب ان
نكون موحدين ونضع جانبا كل خلافاتنا
وتناقضاتنا الثانويه
لمجابهه هذا العدو المحتل الغاصب المتغطرس
الارهابي
اللي بالغفير استاذ عزام وبالتالي يعني كل
الحديث كل الحديث عن الاستفراد بحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي التي تتعارض سياساتها مع
سياسات الفصائل بالداخل لن يؤثر على الرد
الذي يحضر لهذه العمليات
يعني يبدو من منطقه من منطقه الى اخرى
يختلف الوضع اليوم عندما هجموا منزل في
نابلس واستمعتوا بالمناسبه
المصابين بهذا الحجم من في نابلس من هم
من الغاز
والاختناق هم طلبت مدارس من مختلف القوى
ومن عامه الشعب الفلسطيني تصدوا جميعا
تصدوا جميعا بوحده موحده من يحمل البندقيه
الصدى بفندقيته ومن لا يحمل بندقيه
اسمح ليبقى معي ابقى معي لو سمحت سنستمع
مشاهدينا الى هذا التقرير مع كل تصعيد بين
اسرائيل والفصائل الفلسطينيه في غزه تبلغ
صوره مؤثره لاطفال سقطوا ضحايا لغارات
وصواريخ لا ترحم اكثر من 2000 طفل قتلوا
في غزه خلال جولات التصعيد في السنوات
الاخيره فيما ترك الاخرون بمشاكل نفسيه
كبيره فلنسم على هذا التقرير واعود
وصلت الطفله ميرال الى المستشفى تريد
اباها ولم تعلم انها صارت يتيمه ابوها
وامها قتل في الهجوم الاسرائيلي
طفله بحاجه لتدخل نفسي عاجل هي وثمانون في
المئه من اطفال غزه وفق منظمه انقذوا
الاطفال الدوليه ست حروب سابقه على غزه
تركت اثار النفسيه مدمره على اطفالها
الحروب المستمره على قطاع غزه لابد ان
تترك اثارا انيه واثار بعيده المدى
بالنسبه للاثار الامنيه وخلال الساعات
والايام القادمه قد يرى الاهالي مجموعه من
الاعراض تظهر على ابنائهم الخوف الشديد
نوبات من الهلع عدم قدره على النوم او حتى
تقيؤ غير مفهوم السبب او حتى اشكال اخرى
من الاضطرابات في الجهاز الهضمي
لما اعتبرت ميرال من الناجين فان علي
وميار وهاجر لم ينجو قتلتهم الصواريخ
الاسرائيليه وهم في فراشهم وامسوا وقود
حرب لا ترحم
اكثر من 2000 طفل قتلوا خلال السنوات
العشرين الاخيره
ذنبهم الوحيد انهم ولدوا في غزه
عدنا اليك استاذ عزام الاحمد عضو اللجنه
التنفيذيه لمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه طبعا
هذا تقرير ياتي بصلب ما كنت تتحدث عنه من
استهداف المدنيين وللاطفال ومن استهداف
عشوائي طبعا اليوم السؤال الاساسي الذي
يشغل بالجانب الاسرائيلي هو ما اذا كانت
ستشارك حركه حماس بالهجوم المضاد هل هناك
يعني اعلم ان كل المعطيات سريه ولكن الرد
هل نتوقع الرد قوي ام سيكون رد مفاجئ كما
تفعيل عمليات الاغتيال كانت مفاجئه
يعني نحن في مجابهه مفتوحه في كافه
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله من جنين حتى
رفح
والقدس بينهما ايضا
والخليل لذلك
يعني نرى هناك
تلاحم نضالي بين كافه القوه والفصائل حماس
طبعا بصراحه لديها دائما
رؤيتها الخاصه بها احيانا تشارك في الرد
واحيانا لا تتدخل لا تتدخل اطلاقا
وسبق انبيد قال انه عمل على تحييدها بعيدا
عن حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
وبينهما ايضا علاقات ثنائيه نامل ان يكون
هناك تفاهم بين الجميع لتوحيد
المواجهه مع اسرائيل عندما بن غفير
يرفض المشاركه في اجتماعات الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الاسبوعيه الا اذا اسرائيل
مارست القتل ضد الشعب الفلسطيني وحتى ضد
المعتقلين الفلسطينيين علينا ان نجابههم
بنفس
الاسلوب
وخصوص من الحكومه يعني هو يحدد بسقوط
حكومه نتنياهو استاذ عزام شكرا انتهى
الوقت استاذ عزم الاحمد عضو اللجنه
التنفيذيه لمنظمه تحرير الفلسطينيه على
هذه المداخله
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
منظمه الهجره الدوليه على التجاوز اعداد
النازحين داخل السودان لاكثر من 700 الف
شخص
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد هجوم جديد شنو هو مؤسس
فاجنر على المسؤولين الروس وهذه المره
تجاوزت الدفاع الروسيه ووزير الدفاع ووجه
سهامه واتهاماته الى المشككا بقدره الكريم
على الدفاع عن البلاد في وقت تستعد
اوكرانيا لهجوم المضاد اتهموا ايضا وحده
عسكريه تابعه لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه
بالفرار من مواقعها قربه بخمول قائد فاجنر
قال ايضا انه تلقى امرا بالبقاء في مخموض
والا اعتبر خائنا
[موسيقى]
طلبنا في ليله الثامن من مايو ذخيره
واسلحه لكن لم نتسلم سوى عشره في المئه من
المطلوب ومن الواضح الاصرار على مراجعه
طلباتنا وتقليصها ما يزال الوضع على اطراف
ضخمه متوترا بينما تركت وحدات من وزاره
الدفاع المواقعها التي حاربت قوه فاغنر من
اجل السيطره عليها بالدماء ولفتره طويله
بينما يكدس الاوكرانيون اسلحتهم ويحشدون
قواتهم الاحتياطيه لو وصلت الذخيره كما
نريد لكن الان نتقدم وكنا منذ فتره طويله
في سلوفيا
لذات قائد ومؤسس فا ياخذها الكرملين بكل
تاكيد بعين الاعتبار كون انسحاب هذه
المجموعه يعني انهيارًا جديدا لروسيا شرقي
البلاد اذا البدايه من جبهه بخموت هذه
الجبهه التي تسيطر عليها قوات فاجنر
تقريبا على كامل هذه المنطقه هي موجوده
بالوسط وعلى طرفي هذه المنطقه ولكن هنا
مشاهدينا الصراع يتركز الان بالمنطقه
الغربيه لبخموت لاحكام السيطره عليها طبعا
مخموت للتذكير هي تعتبر نقطه وبلده الصمود
وهي عنوان للصمود الاوكراني ومن هنا فان
سقوط هذه البلده يعني سقوط شيء رمزي كثيرا
بالنسبه للاوكران اذا ايضا يعني بموازاه
هذه السيطره اذ هنا يهدد رئيس فاكتور بانه
في حال سقطت هذه الجبهه يعني انهيار
الجبهه باكملها وانسحابها يعنيها انها
ستكشف مناطق سيطره القوات الروسيه
انا اتحدث عن هذه المناطق هنا اي عن
الديفكا وعن لمن وايضا المناطق المحيطه
بمحمود ننتقل من مخموت الى سوليدار
ايضا هناك ايضا القوات طبعا قوات فاجنر
موجوده بهذه المنطقه المحاذيه لبخموت
وايضا التابعه لدونيسكي اداريا مقاتلوا
فاغنر ينتشرون هنا ايضا بهذه المنطقه داخل
مناطق عده لمقاطعه لوجاسك اذا هذه المناطق
السيطره عليها تعتبر استراتيجيه وسقوط
احدى هذه الجبهات كما يهدد مؤسس فاجنر
ايضا سيؤثر على الجبهه جبهه روسيا بموازاه
تحضير اوكرانيا لما اصبح يعلم بالهجوم
المضاد
كان هذا اليوم الموعود للاستيلاء على
باقمه الاوكرانيه رمزيه النصر في يوم
النصر وفقا لقائد قوات باغنر والقياده
الروسيه ايضا لكنه تحول الى اعنف هجوم
يشنه
على قيادات
لا يجب ان يموت الجندي بسبب الغباء المطلق
للقياده في موسكو الجنرالات والضباط على
الارض ملزمون بتنفيذ هذا الغباء لان
الاوامر التي تصلهم من الاعلى هي اجراميه
بكل ما تحمله الكلمه من معنى غباء القياده
هذا ليس الاحتراف الوحيد الذي كشفه زعيم
قوات فاجنر فالرجل رفع من سقف حربه مع
رجال الكرملين حددت تشكيك بقدره الحكومه
الروسيه في الدفاع عن البلاد
اوكرانيا تضرب المناطق الحدوديه الروسيه
بنجاح لماذا الدوله الروسيه غير قادره على
الدفاع عن البلاد
جنرالات الكريميلين كانوا مشغولين بنصب
المكائد بدلا من القتال يقول بريكوجين امر
انعكس على جبهات القتال ودفعت جنود الروس
الى الفرار من ساحات المعارك جبن مبطن
للجيش تهمهم به طبخ كما كان يطلق عليه
فوفقا للرجل فان وحده عسكريه روسيه فرت
مؤخرا من مواقعها قرب باخموت ما جعلت جبهه
مكشوفه على خطوط القتال التي تتمركز فيه
قواته كما لم تتلقى مجموعته سوى عشره
بالمئه من الذخيره اللازمه للقتال امر
اعتبره الرجل جريمه لتدمير الشعب الروسي
ايام وتنسحب فاجنر من تخوم باخموت يقول
فحتى بوتين مخدوع من قبل جنرالاته في
الحمله العسكريه في اوكرانيا خداع قال
انهم سيدفعون ثمنه على يد القائد او الشعب
الروسي اذا خسر الحرب رائد المصطفى
العربيه
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا عبر زوم من دبي رياض
قهوجي البحث في شؤون الامن والدفاع سابدا
يعني بالفتره الماضيه كنا نسمع كل الهجوم
لقائد فاجنر على الدفاع الروسيه كانت صراع
داخل المؤسسه العسكريه اليوم تطور هذا
الصراع اصبح بين فاجنر وبين الكريم اصبح
يوجه الانتقادات للكريم تحديدا وبالتالي
هل هنا نتحدث عن تكتيك سياسي عن ابتزاز
للحصول على مزيد من الدعم بظل توقيت حرج
للقوات على الارض ام انه صراع على السلطه
فقط
هو مزيج من اثنين يعني هي بالنهايه
مؤسسه خاصه
تخدم مصالح قاده الكرمله او قاده الكرملين
هي تاخذ اموال مقابل خدمات حتى من الحكومه
الروسيه يعني هي دورها اليوم التي تؤديه
في اوكرانيا هو مقابل اموال تدفع من
الحكومه الروسيه
دخلت في الجبهه الاوكرانيه وهي تروج انها
ستحدث
انتصارات عجزت عنها المؤسسه العسكريه يعني
هو عليه ان يظهر ان هناك عاجز ليظهر ان
هناك حاجه له
ولقواته يعني هناك تنافس بين مؤسستان
عسكريتين مؤسسه خاصه هي ومؤسسه الدوله هي
القوات المسلحه النظاميه وهنا هذه
ما يجري اليوم على الساعه في اوكرانيا
وهذا التضادع الذي نراه طب هل نتحدث يعني
عن عجز الكريم عن اداره التوازن العسكري
بين القوات الخاصه وبين القوات الرسميه
على الارض
هناك حال من الفوضى بين الطرفين هذا بات
واضح عندما يكون هناك انتقاد بهذا الشكل
وحتى تهديد بانسحاب من خطوط اماميه مهمه
يعني هذه الاشهر التي امضتها القوات
الروسيه الروسيه مع قوات فاجنر للوصول الى
وصلت اليه في باخ نوت
يبدو انها ستزول يتحدث عن انسحاب ترك خطوط
اماميه
وبالتالي
هذه حاله من الفوضى هذه حاله تعكس انهيار
في معنويات وتحادث تضارب
اصبحت تتحدث عن صراع على الارض موجود بين
فاجنر وبين يعني عن قتال وبين القوات
الرسميه استاذ رياض هل يمكن اليوم بهذا
التوقيت الذي يعتبر يعني حرج جدا بالنسبه
للروس استبدال فاجنر بالمرحله المقبله باي
من القوات الخاصه خصوصا وان يعني هناك
قوات قديروف هناك قوات اخرى ممكن انشاء
تحت اي مسمى اخر وهي ضمن العقيده العسكريه
الروسيه منذ زمن طويل
هناك بيت واضح ان هناك شهاده من
الاورجاركيه الروسيه التي تستفيد منر تريد
الحفاظ على قوات
غير نظاميه كمرتزقه لتاخذ اموال طائره من
الدوله بحجه انشاء قوات للحرب في اوكرانيا
ولتتمكن من ذلك عليها ان تظهر ان هناك عجز
وفشل في القياده العسكريه هذا في وقت
اداره قياده العسكريه ليس من مصلحتها ان
تمكن هذه القوات من احداث النصر على
حسابها ومن هنا هذه المنافسه بنهايه الامر
يجب ان تكون هناك قوه واحده على الارض
واعتقد ان الجيش قد يستغل هذا الوضع
لينهي وجود مصلحه الجيش الروسي ان ينتهي
وجود فاجنر خاصه في اعمالها على الجبهه
الاوكرانيه لانها باتت تؤثر على معنوياته
تؤثر على مكانه مكانه الجنرالات فيها
اخذ يعني عند حدوث اي تقدم يكون النصر
لصالحهم وليس لصالح جماعه فارغنار شكرا لك
رياض قهوج البحث في شؤون الامن والدفاع
حدثتنا من دبي
احتفلت روسيا بالذكرى الثامنه والسبعين
للنصر على النازيه وصفته النيورك تايمز
بيوم النصر الصامت لكن لماذا الجواب يظهر
في الغاء استعراض سلاح الجو الروسي لاسباب
امنيه وتقليص الاحتفالات في اكثر من 20
مدينه والغاء المسيرات العسكريه والشعبيه
تحسبا من اضطرابات داخليه وفق الصحيفه
ورغم ذلك استعرضت روسيا عضلاتها العسكريه
في الساحه الحمراء في موسكو حيث جلس رئيس
روسي بين عدد من الضيوف الاجانب والمجموعه
من المحاربين القدامى وجنرالات الجيش على
منصه اقيمت للاشراف على العرض العسكري
الذي شاركت فيه وحدات عسكريه ضمت نحو 10
الاف جندي ومئات المركبات والاليات
والانظمه الصاروخيه
[موسيقى]
في هذا اليوم الذي يعتبر الاحب الى قلب
بوتين شدد ان مواطني بلاده متحدون في
معركه مقدسه مع الغرب حول اوكرانيا وسوف
تنتهي بالنصر مشيرا الى ان مستقبل الدوله
الروسيه يعتمد على المشاركين في العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا طبعا بعدما
شنت حربا حقيقيه على بلاده فلنستمع لما
قالها
اليوم حضارتنا مره اخرى تشهد نقطه تحول
حاسمه وتندلع حرب حقيقيه مره اخرى ضد
وطننا لكننا قاومنا الارهاب الدولي سنقوم
ايضا بحمايه سكان الدومباس وضمان امننا
بالنسبه لروسيا لا توجد دول معاديه سواء
في الغرب او في الشرق كما هو الحال مع
الغالبيه المطلقه من الناس على هذا الكوكب
نريد ان نرى المستقبل سليما وحرا ومستقرا
[موسيقى]
مع دخول الازمه السودانيه يومها الرابع
والعشرين كشف المتحدث باسم المنظمه
الدوليه للهجره بان اكثر من 700 الف نازح
سوداني نزح داخليا بسبب القتال الذي بدا
في الخامس عشر من ابريل مؤكدا ان الرقم
تضاعف في غضون اسبوع
بحسب المعلومات التي جمعتها فرقنا
الميدانيه فان اعداد النازحين داخليا في
السودان تضاعفت خلال الاسبوع الماضي وهناك
الان اكثر من 700 الف نازح داخليا بسبب
القتال الذي بدا في الخامس عشر من ابريل
هذا ووصلت اولى طلاء على الجسر الجوي
السعوديه الى مطار بورتسودان لمساعده
الشعب السعودي من جهه اخرى اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع السعوديه في بيان لها عن تنفيذها
لست رحلات اجلاء منذ بدء عمليات الاجلاء
من السودان الى المملكه كما اورد بيان
وزاره الدفاع عن بلوغ عدد من تم اجلائهم
عبر طائرات القوات الجويه الى السعوديه
نحو 530 شخصا بينهم سعوديون واخرون ينتمون
رساله 23 دوله
تستعد الى طائرات وطلائع الجسر الجوي
السعودي اللغاتي لمساعده الشعب السوداني
بالاقلاع عبر عديد من المساعدات التي سيتم
ارسالها عبر هذه الطائره العسكريه التي
ستحمل بعشره اطنان موزعه على عدد من
المساعدات الهوائيه والغذائيه والدوائيه
وتحمل على متنها ايضا فريق من مركز الملك
سلمان بالاضافه الى فريق حمايه سيذهب
مباشره الى مطار بورتسودان لانزال هذه
المساعدات مباشره كما انه سيكون هنالك
طائره اخرى ستقلع بعد ساعات من مطار
الرياض الى بورت السودان لانزال المساعدات
مباشره الى المطار السوداني سنتحدث اكثر
مع الدكتور سامر الجطيلي متحدث الرسمي
باسم مركز الملك سلمان للغاته والاعمال
الانسانيه دكتور حدثنا عن اولى طلائع هذا
الجسر وما تحميله من مساعدات
حياكم الله
تنطلق اول طائره يتم تحويلها تحميلها
حاليا وهي اول طائره من الجسر الجوي انفاذ
لتوجيهات سيدي خادم الحرمين الشريفين
واوليعه الامين
بتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه والاغاثيه
للشعب السوداني الشقيق هذه الطائرات تحمل
حوالي عشر اطنان من المواد الغذائيه
والمواد الايوائيه وكذلك المواد الطبيه
والتي تمثل الحقيقه اهم الاحتياجات في هذه
المرحله سوف تتبع هذه الطائره طائره اخرى
اليوم وسوف يستمر هذا الجسر الجوي باذن
الله عز وجل حتى نصل الى مستهدفنا وحتى
نحقق التوجيه السامي الكريم بايصال
المساعدات للاشقاء في السودان هذا اول
الخير نسال الله عز وجل التوفيق ونسال
الله عز وجل ان نكون على قدر هذه المهمه
الكبيره التي وليت لنا في مركز الملك
سلمان الشكر الجزيل لوزاره الدفاع للقوات
الجويه الملكيه السعوديه والتي الحقيقه
تقوم الان مشكوره بهذا الجسر الجوي نسعى
باذن الله عز وجل لتحقيق اثر وصناعه
الحقيقه تغيير في حياه المحتاجين في هذه
المرحله من الازمه والصراع في السودان
شكرا جزيلا الدكتور اذا تستعد هذه الطائره
الى الاقلاع بعد قليل وهي هذه الطائره
ستحمل هذه
المساعده الواقعه بين بورتسودان الى
الخرطوم على ان تستمر هذه العمليه خلال
الايام القادمه وسط حمله شعبيه نودي لها
هنا بالسعوديه للتبرع على ان تستمر هذه
الى ايام واسابيع قادمه وان تصل الى كافه
الولايات السودانيه
التي تحتاج هذه المساعدات بشكل عاجل عبد
المحسن الحربي لقناتي العربيه والحدث
الرياض
التاسعه مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد قليل
امر قضائي يمن اذان ترامب من تداول قضيتهم
مع وسائل التواصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
التركيه ان الوزير مولود شاوج اوغلو
سيلتقي وزراء خارجيه سوريا وروسيا وايران
في موسكو باول لقاء من نوعه منذ عام 2011
اقرت الخارجيه التركيه ان اللقاء الذي
سينعقد في موسكو سيناقش تطبيع العلاقات
بين تركيا وسوريا الى جانب العمليه
السياسيه واعاده اللاجئين الى بلادهم بشكل
امن
[موسيقى]
يترقب العالم الانتخابات التركيه والصراع
ما بين كمال
والرئيس الحالي اردوغان الذي قاد البلاد
لمده عقدين ويقاتل بشراسه للفوز بعقد ثالث
في الحكم التركي ولكن لماذا الانتخابات
التركيه مهمه جدا للعالم اجمع سؤال طرحته
وصحيفه
في ظل حكم اردوغان نمى دور تركيا كوسيط
اقليمي ودولي بشكل كبير وسيتم مراقبه
نتائج الانتخابات عن كثب في اوروبا وحلف
شمال الاطلسي والنيتو تقول هنا الصحيفه
طبعا وربما لن تراقب اي دوله اوروبيه
الانتخابات التركيه عن قرب اكثر من السويد
التي عرقل اردوغان محاولتها لتصبح عضوا في
حلف شمال الاطلسي على الرغم من ان تركيا
صوتت الشهر الماضي لسماح لفنلندا
بالانضمام الى نيته في وقت اكدت المعارضه
التركيه انه في حال فوز هذه المعارضه لن
يكون عقب بوجه طموحات السويد ووعدت بتنشيط
العلاقات التركيه المتوتره مع اوروبا
والتعاون بشان ملف الهجره
الانتخابات التركيه مشاهدينا مهمه ايضا
لمسار الحرب في اوكرانيا لسببين رئيسيين
اولا لان تركيا طرحت نفسها وسيطا واستضافه
جوله اوليه من المحادثات الدبلوماسيه بين
موسكو
والتي سرعان ما تلاشت مع الشداد طبعا
وتيره الحرب والصراع اما السبب الثاني
فيكمن بمساعده انقره لتوقيع الاتفاق
الاممي الاستئناف شحنات الحبوب التي كانت
روسيا قد حاصرتها
[موسيقى]
يشكل الناخبون الاكراد نسبه لا باس بها من
عدد الناخبين في تركيا ولهم دور مهم في
الانتخابات
ويمثلهم عدد من الاحزاب ابرز هذه الاحزاب
واكبرها حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي المعارض
لاردوغان والذي استقطم بدوره حزب الدعوه
الحره وهو حزب محافظ صغير يدعمه الاكراد
المحافظون وبالتالي تحاول كل الاطراف جذب
النسبه الاكبر من الناخبين الكرد فلنتابع
هذا التقرير
رغم عملهما معا في مكتب بسيط للعقارات بحي
اسانيورت في اسطنبول الا ان ايدن ونوري
ليس على قلب رجل واحد فيما يخص الانتخابات
التركيه القادمه
كلاهما من اكراد تركيا لكن توجهاتهم
السياسيه التي كانت متوافقه فيما مضى
اختلفت في هذه الانتخابات
في سنوات حكمه الاولى كان الحزب الحاكم
جيدا على كافه الاصعده كثير من الاكراد
كانوا يصوتون لصالح حزب العداله والتنميه
لكن في الاونه الاخيره ولا سيما بعد
التدهور الاقتصادي اصبحت مقتنعا بضروره
التغيير لذلك لن اصوت لحزب العداله
والتنميه بل لكم
بان
ساصوت للرئيس اردوغان انا راضا عن سياساته
تجاه الاكراد واحبه شخصيا لذلك سامنحه
صوتي من جديد
تقدر نسبه الاكراد في تركيا ب 15% من عدد
السكان واعتاد حزب العداله والتنميه ان
يكون الحزب الثاني كسبا للاصوات في
المناطق ذات الغالبيه الكرديه خلف حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي الكردي الذي يملك
القاعده الانتخابيه الاكبر في اوساط
الاكراد لكن طليق الذي مارسته الحكومه ضد
الحزب الكردي وسعيها لاغلاقه دفع الكثير
من الاكراد الى اعاده النظر بموقفهم
السياسي من الحزب الحاكم في البلاد
تحسبا من قرار الاغلاق قرر حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي خوض الانتخابات باسم حزب
اليسار الاخضر واسست تحالفا للاحزاب
اليساريه وهو تحالف العمل والحريه
التحالف الجديد قرر عدم اختيار مرشح
للانتخابات الرئاسيه بل قرر دعم مرشح
المعارضه كمال كلجدار اوكلو ضد اردوغان
كما ذكرتم يبلغ عدد الاكراد في تركيا ما
بين 12 الى 15 مليون مواطن الحزب الذي
يعتبر ذاته ممثلا للاكراد في تركيا حصل في
الانتخابات الاخيره على خمسه ملايين صوت
وهذا يعني ان ليس جميع الناخبين الاكراد
يصوتون وفق معيار الهويه العرقيه بل هناك
هويه الدين وكذلك دوافع اقتصاديه وغيرها
من المعايير التي تحدد توجه الناخب التركي
في عمليه التصويت في مقابل دعم حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي لمرشح المعارضه استطاع تحالف
الشعب وهو الائتلاف الحاكم جذب حزب الدعوه
الحره والمعروف باسم حزب هدى بار الى
تحالفه ويستقطب هدى بار المحافظين الاكراد
ويعتبر من الاحزاب الاسلاميه المتشدده
لكنه لا يحظى بشعبيه حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي رغم ان مرشح المعارضه كمالك
الجدار اوغلو انتزع دعما من حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي لكن كتله القوميين في معسكر
المعارضه ترفض هذا الدعم لانها تراه حزبا
مؤيدا لحزب العمال الكردستاني في المقابل
نال انضمام حزب هدى بار لتحالف الشعب
استياء بسبب تهم تلاحق الحزب بارتكاب
اعمال ارهابيه هي معادله معقده تعكس
اختلاط المصالح والتحالفات في انتخابات
ليست كسابقاتها زيدان زنجلو العربيه
اسطنبول
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من اسطنبول الدكتور
سمير صالحه الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه
دكتور سمير بانتخابات عام 2019
دعم حزب الشعوب للمعارضه ساهم بسقوط يعني
منطقتين او مدينتين تعتبر الاهم كانت
حينها اتحدث عن انقره وعن اسطنبول اليوم
بظل التحالفات القائمه كيف سيساهم هذا
الدعم يعني
بدعم كل حظوظ المعارضه اليوم وايسر من
ستدفعه المعارضه ايضا بسبب هذا التحالف
صحيح مساء الخير للجميع اولا فعلا يعني
تشريني لاكثر من نقطه سواء كان في التقرير
الذي قدم ولد قبل قليل او في السؤال الذي
تطرحينه الان في اكثر من علامه استفهام
نحن حتى في الداخل التركي نتابع عن قرب
هذه كل تطورات لكن في علامات استفهام ما
زالت عالقه لا نملك اجابات واضحه محدده
عليها اعطيك مثال بسيط حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي نعم المحسوبه على الصوت الكردي
في جنوب شرق تركيا نعم يدعم مرشح المعارضه
كمال وفي انتخابات الرئاسيه لكنه ليس جزء
من التكتل المعارضه كما اشرتهم الحزب
القومي حزب ايه او حزب الخير يرفض التنسيق
مع هذا الحزب هذا الرفض يعني غير مفهوم
كيف يتم الرفض ومع ذلك هو يقرر انه لن
يعلن
مرشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه ويقرر دعم مرشح
المعارضه اذا الحزب الخير او حزبيه يعرف
تماما انه هذا التنسيق لا بد منه اذا كان
في رغبه لدى تكتلات المعارضه بمواجهه حزب
العداله
والتنميه رايي ايضا انه هذا الحزب حزب
الشعوب نعم سيلعب دور بيضه القبان في
الانتخابات المقبله لانه عنده حجم حوالي
10% من الاصوات مجموع الاصوات وقادر تحت
سقف البرلمان او في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
ان يدعم مرشح ويسهل ربما يطيع حدود اكثر
في الفوز ولكن طبعا هنا السؤال الاصوات
التي سيخسرها نتيجه هذا التحالف هل تصب
لصالح اردوغان ام انها ستبقى يعني ليست
محسومه للطرفين دكتور سؤال اخير لو سمحت
اردوغان يعني تاريخيا حافظ على نسبه ما هو
الى 40% من اصوات الاكراد بالمناطق
الموجودين بها اليوم مع كل السياسات
المتشدده التي مارسها بالفتره الماضيه
والخطاب الانتخابي الحاد الى اي مدى سيؤثر
على الصوت الك ردي تجاه اردوغان وحزب
العداله
يعني في مناطق جنوب شرق تركيا تحديدا لا
اظن انه سيكون هناك تحول كبير في اصوات
الناخب الناخب الذي يدعم حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطيه اظن هذا التحول في صفوف
مناصريه هذا الحزب تكون في المدن الكبرى
لذلك انت اشرتي قبل قليل انه انتخابات
2019 دعم الصوت الكردي في انقره واسطنبول
سهل للمعارضه بالفوز في الانتخابات
البلديه في المدينتين الان بالنسبه لمعركه
الرئاسه ايضا هذا الدعم قابل نعم ليكون له
تاثير ايجابي لكن في اكثر من نقطه ايضا
تقلق المعارضه مثلا حزب ايه او حزب الخير
هل سيستطيع ان يوفر هذه الكتله التي وعد
بها كمال كريشت اوغلو ام لا يقال انه
اصوات حزبيه تتراجع يعني في اكثر من علامه
استفهام كما قلت لك لدى الجانبين بينها
موضوع حزب الحركه القوميه اليمينيه وما
الذي سيقدمه من دعم للرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان في الانتخابات الرئاسيه ايضا
وبالتالي نتحدث عن خارطه معقده وعن هشاشه
بدات لحزب العداله منذ عام 2019 باسطنبول
شكرا لك دكتور سمير صالح الاستاذ في
العلاقات الدوليه حدثنا من اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
انفجرت اعمال شغب واشتباكات في كراتشي
بباكستان بعد اعتقال الشرطه الباكستانيه
لرئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان على ذمه
التحقيق في قضيه فساد بعد حكم من المحكمه
العليا باسلام اباد
[موسيقى]
هذا واقتحم مناصرون اسم الوزراء
الباكستانيه السابق عمران خان مقر
الاستخبارات الباكستانيه في مدينه فيصل
ابد وافاد مراسل العربيه انا مدن رئيسيه
باكستانيه تشهد اعمال شغب لانصار حزب
عمران خان واكد ان مناصره عمران اقتحموا
ايضا مقريا عسكريين في منطقتين شمالي شرقي
باكستان
رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان
كان قد قال في مقطع مسجل قبل اعتقاله بانه
مستعد للذهاب الى السجن بمحض اداره ارادته
ومؤكدا بانه ليس مدان باي قضيه تستدعي
لالقاء القبض عليها
اذا كان لدى شخص ما اوامر بالقاء القبض
عليه فاحضروا لي مذكره توقيف سيكون محامي
الخاص بانتظاري انا مستعد للذهاب الى
السجن بنفسه صنعوا مشهد مثير سيهدر
الموارد كما لو كان اكبر مجرم في البلاد
قادما قدموا اوامر مباشره لاعتقالي بالرغم
من عدم وجود اي قضيه ضدي الا انني مستعد
نفسيا للسجن
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من الاسلام اباد رؤوف
حسن مستشار رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني
السابق عمران خازن استاذ رؤوف يعني اعتقال
مفاجئ كنا نتوقع منذ اشهر ولكن بالتوقيت
اليوم مفاجئ من قبل مكتب المحاسبه الوطني
ولا هو يعنى طبعا بشؤون مكافحه الفساد
يعني ما تفاصيل هذا الاعتقال
كان لك تخوف من اعتقاله هناك وسبق كانت
هنالك محاولات كلما
ظهر امام محكمه عليا
بسبب المقاومه الشعب والداعمين لم يتمكنوا
من اعتقاله اما اليوم
تم اعتقاله
وعندما ذهب الى المحكمه العليا في اسلام
اباد
حيث
مثل هناك
عندما دخل المحكمه
قامت جمع شبه عسكريه بمهاجمته
ورفعوه من كرسي
بحسب المحامي الذي كان حاضر وشاهد الحادثه
فقد
سيئه معاملته وضرب
على جسده
وتم جره
الى المركبه حيث اقتادوه بعيدا
فهكذا حصلت الحادثه اليوم
وكما
ذكرتم الرساله المسجله التي قالها اليوم
قال انا مستعد ومستعد نفسيا للذهاب الى
المحكمه حتى الى السجن فهو كان يعرف انه
معاملته والشرطه لم تكن حاضره
الذين اعتقلوا
او القوات التي اعتقلت هي جماعه شبه
عسكريه
ولكن
الشرطه لم تكن حاضره
ولم يرى لها اثرا وهذه مساله اخرى يجب ان
نبحث فيها في الايام المقبله
خان اين هو الان هل لديكم اي معطيات اين
تم احتجازه
يبدو انه في مكتبي الناب في اسلام اباد
والارجاع امام المحكمه صباح الغد
عن الاتهامات الموجهه ضده ولكن
هذه مجرد تكهنات لسنا متاكدين تماما لانه
لا توجد اي رسائل رسميه او بيانات رسميه
من قبل السلطات لذلك نشعر بانه ربما سيكون
باعتقال معتقل قرب مسجد بلال
وهذا حسب
علمنا من المعلومات التي وردتنا
يعني المعار
ضه ذهبوا الى الدعوه الى وانصار طبعا
عمران خان الى الدعوه الى تظاهرات هل
نتوقع غدا تصعيد على الارض
بمقابل هذا الاعتقال
كما شاهدتم بانفسكم
فبدا
الداعمون بالخروج الى الشوارع مباشره بعد
عمليه الاعتقال
وكانت هنالك تظاهرات عبر كافه ارجاء
البلاد ووفقا لاخر الاحصاءات التي
تلقيناها بين 13 16 شخص قتلوا اليوم خلال
تظاهرات
وكان ذلك باطلاق نار مباشر على هؤلاء
الاشخاص المتظاهرين للاسف
فانا
المحاكمه ايضا
وحكوميه وكان هناك تصعيد على الارض هل ما
شاهدناها اليوم
ينذر بتصعيد اكبر بالساعات والايام
المقبله بعد مهاجمه المقر الرسميه
والعسكريه
حتى اللحظه قارب الوقت على منتصف الليل
وتظاهرات مستمره
والحزب تعهد بانهم سيستمرون بتظاهرات ما
لم يطلق سراح عمران خان ويوم غد نعم ستكون
هنالك عمليه
اقفال واعلنت عنها الحكومه حسب الماده 44
والماده 44
فرضت في كافه ارجاء البلاد وحاله الطوارئ
اعلن عنها في اسلام اباد ولكن توقعوا خروج
المتظاهرين باعداد كبيره مطالبين باطلاق
سراحه عمران خان ونامل وندعي ان هذه
المتظاهرات لن تكون عنيفه ولكن اسلوبها
بمواجهتهم من قبل القوات الامنيه واطلاق
النار على المتظاهرين تنبئ
او تظهر بانهم ناويين على خلق حاله فوضى
وانعدام استقرار لن تكون مفيده لبلادنا
نامل انهم سيسمحون
للشعب الباكستاني بالتظاهر بشكل سلمي كما
فعلوا دائما ولكن اسلوب او تصرف من قوات
الامنيه اليوم يبدو انه لن يسمح بحصول ذلك
شكرا لك من اسلام اباد رؤوف
حاسي السابق عمران خان على هذه المداخله
[موسيقى]
بامر ان قضائي يمنع على رئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب تداول قضيته مع
الممثله الاباحيه
قادمه محكمه ولايات نيويورك والمشرف على
قضيه دفع اموال لشراء صمت الممثله
الاباحيه المتعلق بالترامب اصدر امر يقيد
استخدام الرئيس السابق لوسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي فيما يتعلق بهذه القضيه واصدر
القاضي اخوان مرشان مع المدعين العامين في
منهات قرارا ينقص على ان المواد
والمعلومات المقدمه الى فرق الدفاع التراب
هي فقط لاغراض اعداد دفاع في هذه المساله
ختام التاسعه مع العناوين
ترقب لرد الفصائل الفلسطينيه على قصف غزه
ونتنياهو يعلن استعداده لخوض معركه متعدده
الجبهات
ها
يحاولون تضليل بوتين
في اول لقاء منذ 12 عاما وزير الخارجيه
السوري والتركي يجتمعان غدا في العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو
اعتقال عمران خان يشعل غضبا في باكستان
وانصاره يردون باقتحام مقر عسكريه
واستخباراتيه للحكومه
التاسعه انتهت مشاهدينا لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما كل ليله والان الى 360
والزميله راويه راويه مساء الخير ماذا
لديك مساء الخير ليال طبعا هناك تكهنات
الان حول طبيعه وسيناريو الرد الفلسطيني
المتوقع على قصف غزه وايضا في باكستان الى
اين ستتجه الامور بعد اعتقال عمرها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات